well venture star ariana Greenblatt is
busting her tiny booty on Dancing with
the Stars Junior's in fact she and her
partner are Dion have more energy than
anyone who has actually ever lived you
think I'm exaggerating wallet and watch
this
[Music]
are you ready to get that mirror bar
you're gonna win this I am so ready
every time I go onstage I'm like so
nervous but after the Alex I think we
have the best player in the competition
they're amazing they like each other
just like like each other's best friends
yes your best friend this pint-sized
power couple may be dominating on the
dance floor but Ariana is all about
making friends everyone's phone numbers
so we can all have playdates you have a
phone how old are you 10 but it was for
good purposes what are the good purposes
call my mom and dad okay there we go
I don't how is this making you feel
about having kids here
look I'm 24 and single I wanted kids so
bad before this now I'm good so I'm 55
if you've been trying to hook him up he
says yeah they said that she'd kiss Oh
kiss a girl boy he doesn't want to be
her girlfriend
she's coming to the show on Friday oh
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
you